you understand this is not a business trip
another city you miss your apartment
home to your family this you miss the
whole earth this is a completely different feeling
when developing such missions as a flight to
mars
psychologists of course must take into account this
factor
that people will
miss the earth not even nostalgia
come on of
course it is  an unforgettable impression,
especially when the hatch
opens this air of the steppe into the cockpit, goes there
after all this mess with the launcher,
I understand that it all ended with this
air you can’t breathe in, you can
cut bread with a knife,
you can easily stumble and fall and
break,
don’t water the guys
never planted  they gave me the first time to walk
,
if I already spoke in the air by me,
well, since our mission was directed,
as it were, to Mars before us, the flight is
working out the
medical and biological aspects of the flight to
Mars.
There is a survey. There, I did
it.  I liked it
because it  as if in the future, a directed
being reflects the work of an astronaut,
we will live, we ourselves are not
destroyed for expansion, and the exploration of the
near and then deep space is
inevitable in this is the essence of human,
first of all, mars, of course,
you can physically get used to it even without a
soul there, by punishing fire, the percentage of a
person gets used
a longer flight, it’s rather harder
mentally or something,
already a closed volume for a long time, well, quite
stressful conditions,
you miss space when you are on earth,
you know, it starts to pass
some period on earth, when
if the earth didn’t breathe for me every
day, it’s like-  then plus the joy until
a certain period begins when you have already
adapted when you come here and
you start to get bored and bite well,
despite the fact that it is difficult, it’s
probably akin to a climber who
is cutting into the mountains somewhere laid that a
person there are many beautiful places aurora
very impressive, such greenish must be
red, there is an aurora distance like
through this fire, a certain city, start
very beautifully
beautiful ocean atolls there are such
turquoise blue colors, from
these
streets to [ __ ] the free side to fly to
sift over these enthusiasts at once they
don’t understand what the immensity is not
enough greenery just specifically not
enough forests not enough summer winter snow
all that is connected with the land of this you need to
understand somehow psychologists should
develop a set of measures for people
who will fly further
. when I flew, I asked psychologists
to send with a truck just pictures of
land views of nature there forests rivers
birches lakes mountains
I would hang a little modulo  you fly
already as more cheerfully hooked with a glance at the
rope looked and it’s easier for
her scarf mentally to know your berths on the
unitex will appear 5 took there else there be
taken at it is safe actually we
taught up to 9 frags and the interior